wait until i graduate to do something
important I'm a teacher I want to teach
my students well but I don't know how
and I feel like I don't have the
resources research shows that students
can understand best when they're
actively engaged in hands-on learning
this is why we want to build a social
network but for education the Dallas
network connects all stakeholders it
allows teachers to access tutorials made
by other teachers and experts that they
can use for professional development it
allows students to build and share
portfolios said will provide an
incentive for them to be creative and
thirdly it allows donors to do access
the network and see where which areas
their help is most needed when students
wanted a Dallas network they'll see
other students oh they'll see what other
students are making learning as well as
many tutorials on project-based learning
they would also see so many solutions on
how to solve certain things such as
public speaking and other projects when
teachers go on they'll learn the skills
they need to do project-based learning
which is a very select set of skills
including growth mindset has scaffold a
program project how to set up the
classroom they also be able to see the
projects that other teachers have done
and post their material needs and when
donors x is the website they will be
able to see areas where there he'll help
is most needed because every school has
a virtual presence on the network and
every school has a voice to ask for
exactly the sort of resources set of
beads our strategy is to build a
platform and a spread awareness that way
we can go through the education system
through having certification programs we
knew social media and advertising in
education publications we anticipate
that this would take about three to six
months to build the actual platform and
then another six months to a year to
build a network that's really valuable
over for your time a teacher and I'm so
busy with some of these resources like
why why my using this and how amazing is
so wonderfully one of the things about
this website is that there's a very
strong presence of experts which is
another fourth stakeholder that's
connected to those website that we
didn't talk about the it's that we
anticipate that it's actually a design
course so it's not just a matter of so
first we can go through the course and
then they can access individual
tutorials later to boost their knowledge
and then the projects that are posted
are curated either through a rating
system or through somebody actually on
staff saying no it's not quite good
enough let's get it out of the way so it
doesn't distract people how does it go
beyond the early adopter teachers to the
middle of the bell curve what do you
mean bad so they're going to be teachers
who have incredible energy and want to
do project-based learning and will buck
the administration to do that but how do
you reach the next quartile of teachers
that's a great question so if there's a
certification program that goes with the
professional development that's offered
here that can be an incentive so it can
be there's a lot of times there's
professional development requirements
for teachers and if this is then
certified by the state to be one of the
like official ways to do that then the
teachers are getting that pd which they
will then enable them to go past that
point is that I can't do this i don't
have the time to do this because they
have to do professional development and
this would be then one of the ways to
help them actually realize this is
something that's attainable and in
addition if it's something that they're
doing through their sort of required
professional development piece then
they'll also be exposed to it in terms
of the donor recognition part so they'll
realize that again this is something
that is actually accessible because this
one platform
is how are you going to get started with
the content or with the social network
or how he just are getting started well
as we're building the platform I think
that will be the pulling it together the
resources and then having to build the
network once we have resources that are
valuable enough to go